you have to listen and you have to
listen to the people that matter yes
listen internally give them a voice but
when i came into ernex i spoke with
everybody i always do my road show and
the tour listening tour finding out what
the pain points are
where people think our strengths are but
immediately started targeting the market
itself
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders meet david
howland the cmo of ernex
as cmo of earnings david is responsible
for extending awareness and adoption of
earnex's compelling value proposition
into new and existing markets while
promoting the success of its customers
before joining ernex david served as cmo
for quest back followed by longview
solutions helping each sas company scale
by transforming their brand marketing
and go-to-market strategies
previously david led the global brand
and digital marketing for nasdaq helping
drive its growth and transition from a
traditional financial services company
into a fintech pioneer
david howland welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
thank you i'm doing well appreciate the
opportunity to chat
i'm really really excited to have you
here chief marketing officer of ernex
also running the global brand of nasdaq
all of us know what nasdaq is today
but i wonder what it was like and what
that experience was
you know thinking strategically through
creating this global brand in the
financial markets
and so we're gonna have a really fun
conversation thank you so much for
coming tell me a little bit about
yourself and what is it like being a
chief marketing officer sort of as a
career trajectory
so um
interesting i'll start with that last
question in terms of what it was what's
it like as a career trajectory
so it certainly makes sense in
retrospect but
i started out as a cabinet maker in
seattle in the early 90s when nirvana
hit so i had no intention of going into
marketing
no intention of doing anything with
technology you know sas or anything like
that i was really more interested in
creative endeavors and compelling
experiences
and that led to
you know a gig in an art museum as an
assistant curator ended up going more
the design route because i was
fascinated with always with creating
whether it's something physical like
furniture sculpture
and then into something that's more
digital in terms of desktop publishing
and design and naturally things just
evolved towards
doing more brand work more creative work
aligned and it was really at nasdaq
where i had that opportunity to step in
and not just you know run a brand i'd
done that before but to really cut my
teeth in terms of doing something that's
very diverse complex something that has
tremendous impact
earlier in my career i used to say i'd
spend four hours designing something
that four people saw and then i got to
nasdaq where we do things in a very
agile fashion that influenced the global
markets you wake up in the morning and
you have that responsibility and you're
looking at all these different brands
and you have to understand how are you
putting these together into a coherent
story
how do you go about your work with that
challenge
well first and foremost one has to
recognize that what you think the day is
going to hold is not how the day
actually plays out so you have to
approach each and every day each and
every opportunity
as something that is um ultimately it's
fungible it's going to change you're
going to have to respond in the moment
there are always surprises doesn't
matter how packed your meeting schedule
is there's always new things that come
each and every day
throughout and and what i like to focus
on is a way of centering the thinking
how you bring complexity to simplicity
which is ultimately what we need to do
is to think about the market think about
the customer if you're always focused on
the value the impact the need the pain
points
for the customer and your target then
everything coalesces that's the common
theme and it is a tremendously effective
organizing principle
now as an organization and as a brand
that you're creating you know you need
to align people on a vision you need to
align people on a story something that
they can fall in love with and relate to
this is a different story here right i
mean here you're aligning people on
different stories under one umbrella
was that different culturally or a
different challenge you think than what
a traditional cmo has to go through
i think when you're a cmo of a
fast-growing b2b sas company it's
actually a little bit easier to be
honest i think for a traditional cmo of
established company an established brand
it's a large ship that you're going to
be moving incrementally
but you know we have an opportunity
today to essentially completely
revolutionize the markets that we're
focusing on and one of my primary
responsibilities is to be that chief
evangelist officer who is constantly
exciting my colleagues constantly
bringing new ideas constantly providing
the support and the energy behind making
a difference and trying new things
not to fail fast and fail forward but to
make a concerted effort to fundamentally
change the dynamic of where you're
playing and to do so in a smart way
building upon your experience the
experience of your colleagues wouldn't
have time to fail i don't believe in
that we have opportunities to course
correct to make very very strategic bets
based on on our experience and always be
able to be agile in the moment and make
changes accordingly i love it i i love
the i love you know the the intensity
the internationality
but also you know the the excitement
with you with like i can hear how how
fun that experience was for you what
what is you know perhaps one of the most
exciting pieces of that whole journey
and let's include in that also quest
back and the other positions that you've
held in different organizations up until
you know your current role at earnings
what was the most exciting piece of your
journey so far
well i i think it's it's it's discovery
is ultimately the most exciting piece
and part of what i do
there is always something to learn there
is always a corner to peer around
there's always something new to become
an expert at many years ago when i was a
creative director i became an expert at
u.s postal service mailing labels you
know very random thing you know qr codes
very random thing to become an expert at
because that
is what was required in that moment in
time and it was fascinating now do i
know anything about it now of course not
you know left it behind but there's
always something new to discover and if
we think about each day and each
initiative as an opportunity for us
ultimately to grow
and through that growth to be better at
what we're going to try and accomplish
tomorrow
it's a mindset and it's something uh you
know continual discovery continue
improvement embracing the new embracing
that we all have blind spots everybody
has them
let's recognize that let's address it
and uh and move forward honestly
aggressively to to try and identify it
so what i'm hearing you is that part of
the excitement of the journey is the
discovery of of entering these different
organizations diving deep into them no
matter what they do
becoming sort of an expert in and and
you know owning the story of what you're
building and so that you can tell that
story and and figure out how to best you
know position it and that discovery that
maneuvering between different different
things is something that it was really
exciting for you right
absolutely everyone is trying to have
impact
right and if we can tap into
our colleagues their ability to have
impact our teams like to focus on
supporting my team so that they know
that they can take risks
that ultimately we have to take risks we
have to always be reaching
define goals that are a stretch
take risks in getting there be smart
about it but also our prospects and our
customers they have a desire to make
impact to be a hero how do you create
the dynamics so that your prospect and
your customers the champion within their
world i love it
i love it
you know fast forward to earnix you've
done you've held quite a few marketing
officer positions until then but today
you're at ernex what what is the current
challenge that he took upon yourself
you're mentioning the excitement of the
discovery what are you discovering today
with ernex
so earnix is is just it's a for me it's
it feels like a once in a lifetime
opportunity we have a company that is
growing exceptionally well exceptionally
fast
without the benefit previously of of a
best-in-class marketing approach and
that's simply because the dynamic before
was a few really talented sales people
and leaders were able to move the
company forward now to scale i'm
building an entirely new marketing
organization and in doing so aligning
with the market aligning with the
company our goals and the impact that we
fully believe that we have through our
potential but what i love most about it
is that it's a it's a consolidated
a shared vision
of our impact in the market
we essentially are a horizontal sas
offering
you have a digital product you have to
create a price you want to implement
that your strategy end to end through a
single platform
we can handle that we just happen to
focus on insurance and banking and what
i like to say is insurance and banking
may not sound sexy but believe me the
way that we serve these industries
absolutely is
and these are industries that are part
of every single person's lives if you go
back 10 plus 12 years we're talking
about you know occupy wall street and a
whole different time where insurers and
banks were not seen as constructive part
of society well these industries
listened and they learned and they've
understood that not only have we had
insurance and banking for thousands of
years in some form or another but what
the industries have learned is that it's
by serving
their end customers with a
individualized product with a price that
aligns to their needs not some
cookie-cutter approach in terms of the
overall offering that their customers
are going to be happy they're going to
retain those customers for long-term
value
and ultimately ernex is responsible for
driving this they can't do this without
us
so there's a revolution that's taking
place
literally it is a revolution and our
software and our capabilities our
expertise is at the leading edge of
driving this and that is just
tremendously exciting take me back you
know and are actually high 30 000 feet
what's what's the pain point here you
know what is the struggle especially if
we're looking at banking and insurance
digital pricing for digital products
what is the you know what is the
struggle that we've come to you know in
in the in the early 2020s that that is
giving ernex a position to grow here
if i were to simplify it i would say
it's um
data
and continuous change
think about the data that we interact
with on a regular basis
think about the just tremendous volume
and the endless data sources that we can
pull in to the decisioning process and
then think about continuous change from
one moment to the next our needs change
our perspectives change season to season
pre-pandemic pandemic post-pandemic you
know everything about us is in constant
flux
so
how as an institution
how do you take just incredible volumes
and desperate day of disparate data and
how do you pull that together and how do
you identify a moving target a moving
an environment a market that is is
continuously changing how do you make
the right decisions at every point in
time
how do you make sure that you are
aligned with the market how do you make
sure that you're aligned with your
business strategy and essentially from a
very high level what we're able to do
through of course artificial
intelligence machine learning and
automation and all of the depth of
expertise that we've provided is to be
able to provide
literally not just real time but when i
say real time i'm talking about
decisions that are made
with enormous sets of inputs in
milliseconds incredible so you're
joining ernex a year and a half ago as
chief marketing officer
walk me through a little bit you know
what's going on inside your head is
you're figuring out the right story to
be told and you know when you say it
like this it makes so much sense and you
know immediately convinced but i'm sure
that you know this the the the real
conviction that you're bringing with you
here in the the way that you're
positioning it you know it takes time to
evolve right so what is sort of the
process and the journey that you go
through as chief marketing officer with
your organization to align everybody on
what you just shared with me
well i'll go back first to an experience
that i had
uh years ago at nasdaq
so
major global player while i was there we
transitioned the company and i say we i
mean it was the the ceo led this i was
certainly a small part of it but we
transitioned the company from a
traditional exchange business where the
majority of your revenue is coming
through transactions
and you know data and a few things right
indexes just a few things like that but
it's 80 of your business is
transactional meaning you don't control
it markets go up go down volume goes up
goes down and while i was there ceo led
an effort to flip the switch so that it
became 70 subscription based he added a
whole sas component to the company we
became a market technology provider
whereby exchanges and brokerage houses
globally were running on the same
technology that nasdaq was running just
white labeled and resold
and really created a very different
dynamic and as part of that grew the
company by you know literally a
tremendous amount while i was there it
was it was a great journey
so in the latter part of my journey we
executed a full rebrand of nasdaq first
rebrand in the company's history
repositioning of it everything about it
we changed
and uh and what really spurred that on
is
we had done a survey a comprehensive
study of our customers and we thought we
knew who nasdaq was and we thought we
understood the value that we provided to
the market and we couldn't have been
more incorrect we were way off base
and
ultimately we hadn't been listening to
the market into our customers
in favor of of a very inward thinking
narrative and this is what a lot of
companies struggle with whether they
realize it or not and it's not that we
weren't successful it's that our focus
was
undermining the overall potential of the
company and and the breadth of the
vision of where the company could go
so that experience taught me that you
have to listen and you have to listen to
the people that matter yes listen
internally give them a voice
but when i came into earnings i spoke
with everybody i always do my road show
and the tour listening tour finding out
what the pain points are
where people think our strengths are but
immediately started targeting the market
itself customers prospects analysts
media competitors finding out exactly
their perspective outside in and trying
to think about how that reflects to what
we're trying to accomplish and it's a
very difficult thing to do
but it's it's absolutely critical and
and it's an exciting journey and
ultimately it comes down to some of the
lessons i learned in joining ernex is
you can talk about feeds and speeds
we're fast
we're faster than the other guy well
then the other guy says no we're faster
i mean it's when you play with feeds and
speeds you're not talking about value so
how do you raise that up and and the
real challenge is how do you accomplish
something that is truly iconic
you know many years ago salesforce came
forward and said death to spreadsheets
it's a pretty bold thing to say we still
have excel but salesforce is a pretty
big organization
yeah
incredible david were you always
passionate about this
about marketing and um standing the true
value
uh very passionate about the things i do
yes i've always really focused on
mentioned earlier compelling experiences
so building that perfect piece of
furniture
when i was in new york city as an
assistant curator creating these
environments and these experiences that
truly inspired people you know
i didn't make it as a cabinet maker in
part because i wasn't aspiring to a
lifetime as a cabinet maker part of me
wishes i had
but one of the reasons i didn't actually
stay with it and i probably wouldn't
have been successful and the reason i
wouldn't have been successful is
i was the person who spent time making
sure the bottom side of the drawer was
perfect
well no one looks at the bottom of the
drawer the underside of the drawer and
when you're building a piece of
furniture for a commercial business
margins are important and no one is
running a cabinet shop wants their team
to be spending hours on the underside of
something that no one's going to see but
for me it's very much about what's that
moment in time that one moment in time
where someone drops something they go to
pick it up they see the underside and it
needs to be right
so i've always thought about things as a
comprehensive holistic approach
and
it's important for us to remember that
what we perceive is not necessarily the
reality of how it's going to play out
and so we have to try and see around the
corners we have to try to anticipate how
someone's going to interact and we
always have to question
are we communicating what we think we're
saying
are we inspiring people in the way we're
trying to inspire them without that
feedback without that that understanding
that to be inspired you have to try and
inspire but it's through clear and
concise communication it's all packaged
up together and actually i love this
stuff so it's easy for me to be
energetic about it
[Music]
you